hi everyone this is Malcolm ray and
welcome back to Tamra's never seen and
today I am watching Mary Poppins I've
never ever seen this movie in my life
surprisingly I've heard a lot about this
movie from friends and just like people
in general and I've seen all the
references and memes like you know in
guardians of the galaxy I'm Mary Poppins
y'all you know all of that I kind of
expected you know just to be like about
a nanny that kind of you know swoops in
and like helps out kids somehow that
that's my initial thoughts going into
this and she has like magical abilities
and that's literally all I know about
this movie so that's kind of my guess
maybe she's like a witch or a wizard or
a warlock of some nature but other than
that I really have no idea all right so
let's take a look at this
[Music]
Wow I mean
okay I don't know where to start like
this movie was brilliant it's really
kind of like Disney like in in their
element like this is what Disney is
about like as soon as you like watch
this film you can immediately go that
was a Disney film but production the
performances the like the song numbers
like everything just felt like great and
it it was performed really well like
Julie Andrews Dick Van Dyke and the rest
of the cast like just nailed it first of
all Julie Andrews she she's a diamond
it's like I can't begin to describe how
perfect she is for that role like for
boys just her mannerisms the way she
portrayed the Mary Poppins character it
just all worked so perfectly and Dick
Van Dyke say what you will about his
accent he sounded kind of like Steve
Irwin throughout the entire movie right
and but like you kind of like you're
willing to suspend your disbelief for
this entire film do - first of all
Disney magic of course and then just a
simple fact that he's charming as
he's charming is the dude like he just
brings everything like his um his
character is so believable and so
genuine he's just got a charm to him
that just you know just keeps the
momentum flowing the chemistry that he
shares with Mary Poppins Julie Andrews
is just great they just seem like the
best of friends forever and you kind of
feel like there's more to their story
going into this you know I would never
have guessed that Dick Van Dyke had
never danced before because his his
inclination to movement and rhythm is
phenomenal he looked like a seasoned
like dancing professional like you know
Fred Astaire I mean you know I was
putting up high yo but he moves really
really well I was thoroughly thoroughly
entertained it's hard to find things
that are negative about the film I mean
let's see like okay you know dick Van
Dyke's accent it just was all over the
place I didn't know you know what X and
he was trying to he's trying to cockney
but they ended up sounded like you was
doing like a Kiwi dialect and they sound
like he's Australian but that wasn't
really an issue because he was so good
and what else oh yeah there was like a
really weird moment in like some of the
editing was kind of weird we're in it's
understandable because back then they
had limited technology but when they
wanted a shot to you know hold a little
bit longer than they wanted to they
would kind of you know just kind of
rewind it
and then play it back and forth kind of
rewind it and then forward it again just
so that they can have the shot lasts a
little bit longer like there might have
been a issue on production where they
just didn't get the take like it just
either cut or the actor just you know
did something the shot messed up and so
they had to like play it rewind it and
play it forward just so it could you
know work which happen yes so that there
was like some weird editing there the
ending the wrap-up Oh like amidst all of
the magical Mary Poppins going on
amidst all the Mary Poppins going
on there's a subplot between the kids
and their father who's the stern banker
man that wants his kids to be proper
British children grow up in a proper
British home I'm doing my Dick Van Dyke
impression now yeah and so like towards
the end you know the children have
learned to have fun yet you know have
fun responsibly question mark and the
father he's still like a curmudgeon but
you know he ends up losing his job and
as he's like you know they're getting
fired in front of the committee of
bankers he remembers the Mary Poppins
song and just like you know she's like
Oh supercalifragilistic let go and you
know it's like okay cool so you know
he's starting to come into his own but
at this point I feel like I'm starting
to be held hostage because it's like
okay we get it you know he's having a
change of heart you know and you you
look at the clock and it's been well
over two hours I had no idea that this
film was that long that was amazing and
you don't feel it until that part until
they reintroduce this subplot because
everything else just kept the movie
moving along you know from
the moment where Mary Poppins hasn't
clean up their room to when they go to
the top zone I'm calling it the Choctaw
because a lot of people forget that that
was a cartoon but yes that whole
sequence when they're in the chopped
world and the animation and I'm
constantly asking questions like how did
they do that in nineteen in the 1960s
how did they get these effects to work
because CGI Oh was not a thing back then
not really yeah there was just a lot of
great practical effects where you know
they're like riding on the backs of
these animated cartoon turtles there's
like stuff where they're just like Mary
Poppins bag for example like you know
there's clearly like layers there's some
matters matte paintings where people are
like panel walking like you're like wait
that's a painting right but it's like a
long shot and it's clearly either
there's this matte painting but you see
like people moving and you're just like
how how is this happening
it's really a wonder it's a mystifying
movie so uh I'll have even said I really
enjoyed it I was thoroughly entertained
I
I am remiss you could say that you know
this wasn't part of my childhood growing
up I watched all the other Disney movies
you know like Lion King Hercules Ladd
and all that but uh I kind of slept on a
lot of the alive action of movies that
came out through this and I'm glad I saw
this so yeah I
I enjoyed it I gotta give it 10 out of
10 air flips Pistons Bob Dick Van Dyke
can dance that was crazy
like a little like it was wild so there
you got 10 hair flips my hair's gotten a
little bit longer thanks so much for
watching Tamra's never seen see you next
week bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you